hello again this is brian Lindley
producer of plants vs zombies garden
warfare today we're going to be giving
you an extended look at garden ops our
online cooperative mode on the Xbox one
we're also going to be showing off some
of our customized plan characters to
start off we're going to be following
the ice pea shooter here as the plant
team establishes their garden base now
once the garden base is planted the
zombie attack will begin in Mass with
the garden planted the plan team will
start to set up their defenses before
this first way peashooters planting a
daisy hill station model we were looking
at the mystical sunflower she's gonna
plant a fumes room the cactus is gonna
deploy some walnut barriers with the
countdown finished the plants dig in for
the first wave
let's take a look at the mystical
sunflower unlike the normal sunflower
she can hold down the trigger to charge
up for primary weapon to do a much more
powerful blast similar to the mystic
sunflower the future cactus variant also
has a charge up style weapon now if it's
used effectively we can do a lot of
damage in a single shot it's also very
effective in short bursts
here's a quick look at the hot rod
chopper variant will get back to him in
the motor
okay the first wave is complete now the
plants are getting ready for wave to
hear the ice peashooter is using his
routed gattling attack to thin out the
zombie horde from a distance now let's
take a closer look at the hot rod
Chomper bury the hot rod chopper has
less health and a standard chopper but
moves much more quickly by default and
for an added bonus the hot rod chopper
gets a temporary speed boost every time
he chomps is on we're gonna jump ahead
to a boss wave now in garden ops every
three to four waves doctors are bosses
slot machine we spin randomly to
determine what enemies will appear in
last row
ok
looks like we're getting a disco zombie
and a random assortment of zombie horde
in this next way to start this wave the
mystic sunflower is going to tangle with
the disco zombie
let's jump ahead in the action and have
a look at the ICP shooter the ice
peashooter shoots frozen snow peas which
will freeze a zombie after a few
consecutive shots this is a pretty
powerful tactic as it allows the ice
peashooter to immobilize an enemy and
his teammates to finish the job
working as a team is crucial when
battling bosses here the peashooter the
chopper and the sunflower of ganging up
on the disc goes on back to the future
cactus now deploying some walnut
barriers for cover and her charged
attack on another disco zombie
the other plants are going to join the
fray to help finish him off
with the boss wave complete the plants
can now regroup and get ready for the
next wave it looks like they're gonna
have to deal with a surprise attack from
the zombie footballers every so often in
garden ops doctors on Bosh will unleash
an ambush wave using special classes of
zombies these zombie footballers are a
handful the plants need to stay on the
moon and try to take them down quick
feature cactus is using your charge
attack again to take out some
footballers but they just keep coming
the mystic sunflower is multitasking by
healing the cactus we're taking down a
footballer at the same time
one of the plants was just knocked out
by a footballer his plan teammates have
a limited amount of time to get them up
and revive them if all the plants get
knocked down at the same time they fail
the mission and will need to start again
looks like they managed to repel this
surprise attack we're gonna jump forward
a bit to another boss wave the plants
are going to have their hands full as
the zomboss slots landed on a Giga
gargantuar yeti and the disco zombie the
cactus is deploying your garlic drone to
get a better view of the action since
rat wave 10 the zombie assault is really
intensified with several powerful zombie
classes all attacking at once
jump way back to the peashooter now
picking off some zombies with the help
of a nice room and a future the
peashooter heads up to the treehouse to
get a better view of his teammates
battling the Giga gargantuar the get-go
gargantuar just smashed the chopper so
the peashooter uses a hyper speed
ability to get to the chopper quickly
and revive it he just barely gets out of
there with his life looking back from
the tree house the sunflowers using the
rooted Sunbeam attack to finally finish
off to get gargantuan he then jumps down
to street level to heal the alien
peashooter
the zombies keep pressing nonetheless to
get some quick healing and retreats back
to the garden with the zombies closing
in the cactus retreats back toward the
garden to try and secure the base with
her teammates
the plants still have to deal with the
Yeti and disco zombie bosses so now
they've regrouped they head out for the
last push to finish off this way the ice
peashooter engages with the disco
zombies but ends up getting stunned by
the yetis freezer
Getty ice attacks will freeze plants and
do a lot of damage so the plant team
needs to work as a team to take the Yeti
after a flurry of frosty attacks the
plant team finally manages to defeat
Yeti zombies and complete waste and the
plants had defended the garden for 10
waves this last wave requires them to
survive and fight their way to the
landing zone where crazy Dave will pick
them up in his flying RV this final wave
is absolute chaos as dr. zombie
unleashes his whole army to try and keep
the plants from escaping
grab some friends and try out garden ops
when plants vs zombies garden warfare
comes out this February on xbox one and
xbox 360 thanks for watching
you